In this segment we
develop some consequences
of the independence
assumption that we
have made on the trials that
constitute a Bernoulli process.
These properties will
be pretty intuitive,
but they play an important role.
They're helpful in
solving problems,
and they're also quite
helpful in understanding
the continuous time version of
the Bernoulli process, namely
the Poisson process that
we will be studying later.
So here's the story.
We start with a
Bernoulli processes
with some parameter p.
The process starts.
A friend of yours
watches the processes,
and they observe the results
of the different trials,
let's say for five time steps.
And at this time,
right after time five,
they call you into
the room, and you
start watching the
rest of the process.
What will you see?
The first random variable
that you will see
is the result of whatever
happens in this time
slot, which is the sixth
slot of the original process.
The second random
variable that you will see
is the result of the
seventh random variable
in the original
process, and so on.
So the process
that you get to see
is the process
Yi, where i ranges
over the non-negative integers.
What properties does
this process have?
Because of the assumption
that the different trials are
independent, this means
that the first five trials
are independent from the trials
that happen after time five.
So one property is
that the process
is Yi is independent
of whatever happens
in the past, which
is X1 up to X5.
Second, the random variable
that you see, X6, X7, and so on,
are independent Bernoulli random
variables with parameter p.
So the random variables
Yi constitute also
a Bernoulli process
with parameter p.
So the process that
you get to see,
which is the sequence of
trials after time five,
is identical, probabilistically,
to a Bernoulli process
with parameter p
like the process Xi.
So it's as if a Bernoulli
process was just
starting fresh at
this particular time.
And because of this,
we say that the process
has a fresh-start property
after a certain time.
In this example, we used
5 as the certain time,
but instead of 5, we could
have any particular integer
little n, in which case
our process Y1 starts
with Xn plus 1, continues
with Xn plus 2 and so on.
And here, instead of X5,
we would have written Xn.
So after a deterministic
time n, what you see
is the same as if we had
a Bernoulli process that
was starting fresh at
this particular time,
and which is also
independent from whatever
happened in the past.
Let us now complicate
the story a little bit.
Suppose that your friend
watches the Bernoulli process,
and they keep watching
it until a success is
observed for the first time.
Right at that time, they
call you into the room,
and you started watching
the rest of the process.
This is the length
of time that we
have called T1, the number of
trials until the first success.
So what is it that
you will be watching?
The first random variable
that you will see
is what happens
in slot T1 plus 1.
The second random
variable that you will see
is what happened in slot
T1 plus 2, and so on.
And this defines,
again, a process,
the sequence of the
Yi's This is what
you will see starting
from this particular time.
What kind of process is it?
Well, these trials
happened in the past.
We know what they were.
But no matter what they
were, the future trials
will still be
independent of the past,
and each one of the
trials will have
probability p of
being a success.
So the properties
that we have, again,
is that the trials
that you see are
independent of the
past, which in this case
is everything from
x1 up to time xT1.
And what you see is
a Bernoulli process.
We describe the
situation by saying
that the process starts
fresh after time T1.
And by this, again,
we mean that if you
start watching the process right
after T1, what you will see
will be a Bernoulli
process which
is independent from whatever
happened in the past.
Having just argued
that the process starts
fresh at the time T1
of the first success,
we can now ask why whether
such a property is also true
more generally.
That is, if we start watching
the process at some random time
n, will the process
start fresh at that time?
Let us look at some
additional examples.
Suppose that capital N is the
time of the third success.
So your friend watches
the Bernoulli process,
and each time, they say,
did the third success occur?
Not yet.
Yes, the third
success just occurred.
And at that time, they
call you into the room
and you start to watching what
happens from that time on.
What will you be seeing?
After that time, there will be
independent Bernoulli trials
that take place.
And these refer to the future
of the process, looking at [it]
from this particular
point in time.
And the future is
independent from whatever
happened in the past.
So what you actually see is,
indeed, a fresh Bernoulli
process that starts
here and which
is independent from the
random variables that
occurred in the past.
Let us look at another example.
Let capital N be the first time
that three successes in a row
have been recorded.
So your friend, again,
watches the process.
And they ask each time, did
we see three success in a row?
Not yet.
Yes.
I just saw three
successes in a row.
And now your friend
calls you in,
and you start
watching the process
from this point in time.
By the same argument
as before, whatever
happens in the future is going
to be Bernoulli trials that
are independent from the
past, so you will, again,
have a fresh-start property
starting from this time.
So in both cases,
formally, what we have
is that the process that you get
to observe starting after time
capital N, after the time
that you're called and asked
to start watching,
what you will see
is going to be a sequence of
independent Bernoulli trials,
that is, a Bernoulli process.
And this sequence
of future trials
is independent from
whatever happened
in the past of the process.
What both of these
examples have in common
is that the random variable
N, the time at which you're
called in, is
causally determined
from the history of the process.
What does that mean?
It means that somebody
is watching the process,
and at each point in time, based
on what they have seen so far,
they decide whether
to call you in or not.
What would be an example
of a non-causal time N?
Here it is.
N could be the time just before
the first occurrence of 1,
1, 1.
So in this example here, you
would be called into the room
and start watching at this time.
So your friend somehow knows
that a sequence of 1,1, 1
is going to occur and calls
you just before it happens.
How could that be?
Well, imagine that the
Bernoulli process actually
was run yesterday.
It was recorded in a movie.
Your friend has seen
the movie, so knows
everything that's
going to happen.
And so, when the movie
is replayed today,
your friend can call you in
at this time and tell you,
you know, something very
interesting is about happen.
Come in and start watching.
Now, what will you be watching?
What you will watch will
be 1, 1, 1, with certainty.
You're certain that the first
three trials that you will see
will be 1's.
And, well, the subsequent
one's will be random.
But since you know that the
first three trials will be 1,
this means that
statistically, they're
not described by the statistics
of a Bernoulli process.
In a Bernoulli
process, each trial
has a probability of being 1
and the probability of being 0.
But since, in your case,
you're certain to watch
1's in the beginning, this
means that the random variables
that you see do not conform to
the description of a Bernoulli
process.
So this is an example in which
N is not causally determined.
And in this example,
you do not to get
to see a Bernoulli process.
We do not have the
fresh-start property.
What happened here is
more generally true.
We do have a fresh-start
property, but not always.
We have it under the assumption
that the time at which you're
asked to start
watching is determined
from the past history of the
process in some causal manner.
This is a general fact that
can be established rigorously.
However we will not go through a
formal mathematical derivation.
The formal argument for
the most general case
involves somewhat tedious
symbol manipulations
that do not provide
any additional insight.
However, the intuition
behind this result
should be fairly clear,
and we will use it freely
whenever we need it.